[Music]
every now and then a celebrity will coin
the term and it catches on and you
coined a term not too long ago that had
me completely confused so maybe you
could explain it and it's already a
raunchy show so I'm just gonna go for it
okay sometimes I try and preserve the
integrity of the show for up to 10 or 15
minutes but tonight that's gone so I
think we might as well just go for it
the term that you coined that caught on
with people is called vajazzling yes and
I don't I'm just curious what that is I
have no idea
it is it is bedazzling but for your
great hoo-ha right your private if your
lady air areas yes sweet lady yes it is
strange thing to say no it's it's like
it's like having a sparkly secret in
your pants okay now wait a minute is
that something that someone and again
I'm admitting I'm very honest on the
show that I kind of square I don't know
about things is that something that
people that ladies do occasionally
bedazzle
down there I do it all the time
[Applause]
I want to be clear those weren't women
clapping to say we're doing it to sister
guys say ya know lots of women do it
lots of women do it it's really caught
on it's sort of a sexy fun little thing
it doesn't always have to be done for a
man it can just be done for yourself to
sort of feel special and cute and
whatever and this is something that I've
never heard of this this is something
that women do they bedazzled that area
which of course is the little fake yes I
draw I brought one for you you brought
what oh the cat save right so this is
what they look like right okay that's a
good sign place over a peace sign yeah
so you just sort of you take you take it
off and then you stick it yeah okay so I
wouldn't obviously yeah I'm a spirit on
you yeah you put it on here somewhere up
here okay but wait so that goes on your
body yeah and then does this make you
feel does it really make you feel
different makes you feel saucy and I
don't know it's kind of fun it's like
walk around and just think that it you
know nobody has any idea of shiny it is
down there I would think the guy would
be shocked you know just yeah these
favorite things are starting to happen
and all of a sudden he goes down there's
like you know a silver mine down
yeah there's there's a quartz formation
mining helmet there's just - it's lit up
there is no difficulty you need lighting
there's gonna be lighting themes next
that's cute do you want me to put it on
you uh yeah where do you want it where
do you want it yeah why don't we just
stick it on your hand just put on my
cheek right here look yeah you just put
it there because your face jazz old I'm
face jazz old
this doesn't feel sexy at all you could
like to put it here yeah why don't you
put it there that's you put it you know
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right so those are things that are
available ladies get your vagazzler it's
so unnecessary it's necessary there no
one no man is gonna be like well all
right hey
[Applause]
[Applause]
you know I think it's all good all
around I'm gonna try it I'm yeah yeah
it's nice Showtime Conan and I are both
gonna be completely Jasleen it shows
where you and I are secretly jazzy when
we walk it will sound like champagne
glasses toasting
you miss a lot we thought about you it's
about our spirit